you think you are Master no sorry even
your penis you cannot control
[Music]
it Rowan I'll throw to you should we
give up on the idea of humans being
either inherently good or evil
yes well there we
go you are saying this as a
Christian we'll get there we'll get
there Sor this is the p this is just a
pitch I'm saying we should give up on
the idea that human beings are
essentially good or essentially evil
because I can't give any sense to that
question to be honest human beings are
damaged changeable vulnerable capable
incapable where along that Spectrum we
place ourselves or anyone else is one of
the biggest cultural and ethical issues
we could possibly be concerned with but
we're always reaching for apparently
simple answers to questions about human
nature which almost any available answer
is going to be not just unhelpful with
but possibly destructive so the short
answer is no we should not think of
human beings as essentially this or that
we shouldn't give up on the categories
of Good and Evil more on that later we
should think what it might be to look at
ourselves and one another
as well sites places where very
different things unfold I totally agree
uh cultur is contingent socially so on
and so on but you have to presuppose
that this is always against a background
of a certain fundamental disorientation
loss which defines human species so no
no good without evil and I think if you
think you can have good without
po evil potential you end up doing real
evil what you brought out this is
absolutely crucial that
no Nazi killers and so on they are not
this demoniac romantic evil no they are
guys who simply think they are doing the
the greatest self sacrifice good for
their own narrow group and so on and so
on yes I I'm thinking about the way in
which um in the
fourth early fifth century St Augustine
talks about the problem of the origin of
evil and I think he would he would be
insisting precisely that there is no
such thing as evil evil is not the name
of something or some person or anything
so be very very careful about giving it
that kind of substance that a bush might
try to out there is something evil
Augustine says we're talking about a
whole range of incapacity I ities
disasters wounds to our perception our
habit our our inter relationship that's
where the language belongs I cannot
restrain from again referring to St
Augustine which who wrote a wonderful
text I hope you know it the nupes and
coena which is wonderful his point is
precisely that sexuality is not evil but
a wonderful Theory a Divine punishment
for evil which is to be like God to know
too much because he for Austine said
that eating the apple means you get to
know too much you want to be like God
controlling and then he say a wonderful
Theory making some obscure Buddhist
references or to India sorry that uh he
said that there are even yogas in India
who can even stop the heart beating but
one thing you can never control is
erection of penis that's why Direction
and sexuality is a sign like you think
you are Master no sorry even your penis
you cannot control it so I love this
crazy but let me go on to more serious
stuff I agree with what you said about
this uh uh social nature of evil and I'm
not afraid to use the word yeah yeah we
should understand look from within uh uh
what we dismiss as evil but please don't
go into that uh Multicultural
for me at least which says an enemy evil
enemy is just somebody whom we were not
ready to listen to to understand now
thanks I if you read Hitler you will not
discover a human side there or whatever
you will be even more horrified that is
to say evil we humans are Masters in
justifying horrible acts by constructive
a narrative which which makes them
acceptable uh stalinists were Masters
indeed and others here I would like to
return to uh Hanah arand who me you in a
crucial text early one I think she draws
a wonderful difference between sa the
early Nazi tax and SS she said sa a
those who were perched in 34 were vulgar
brutal evil raping beat think and so on
with SS you get something much more
horrifying you get this cold impersonal
burocratic evil to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest
ideas